The idea of making a big deal of revisiting an experience in memory...
...sounds a little strange or simply sad.
We are not assiduous or devoted cultivators of our past experiences.
We shove all the nice things that have happened to us...
...at the back of the cupboard of our minds...
...and don't particularly expect to see them ever again.
They happen, and then we're done with them.
They do sometimes come back to us, unbidden.
We may be on a boring train ride to work...
...and suddenly, an image of a beach at dusk comes to life.
Or, while we're having a bath...
...we remember climbing a flower-covered mountain with a friend a decade before.
But little attention tends to get paid to such moments.
We don't engineer regular encounters with them.
We may feel we have to dismiss them as daydreaming or thinking about nothing.
But what if we were to alter the hierarchy of prestige a little,...
...and argue that regular immersion in our memories...
...is a critical part of what can sustain and console us.
And not least, is perhaps the cheapest and most flexible form of entertainment.
We should learn, regularly, to travel around our minds...
...and think it almost as prestigious to sit at home and reflect on a trip...
...we once took to an island as to trek to this island encased in our cumbersome bodies.